欢迎你学习白泽国际站运营实战系统课
同学们,这一节课我们来讲一下关于我们的店铺如何突出公司的优势, 让客户更加信任我们快速成交, 所有的成交都是基于信任才会产生的
所以为什么有的客户跟你聊聊了,他就不成交了, 或者是说他本身是非常有需求的, 但是你就是成交不了, 除了价格体定量的问题
还有另一个就是你给客户的感觉, 或者是说你的专业度给客户呈现的时候, 可能客户感觉得到一个是不够诚信, 第二个就是你公司实力跟他不匹配, 这就会导致你的成交很难
那么我们如何向客户呈现我们的公司的优势呢? 第一个优势有一个是服务优势, 第二个就是产品优势
我们有些产品或者是说有些行业他是提供一些解决方案的
比如说我们的产品优势就是产品的卖点
服务优势比如说我们提供什么样的服务
然后方案的话比如说售后服务以及本地的一些
维修
这些都是解决方案
所以我们要突出我们公司的优势一定要从产品维度以及我们
销售业务等这些方面去做扶持, 比如说你的行业或者是你们的产品是在招代理的
你有对代理的扶持会有一些什么
一个是资料一个是
一些物料比如说那些品牌广告等等宣传的一些物料
这些是不是有支持有提供
所以这些代理他是非常看重这种的
因为这些都会涉及到一定的成本
所以如果你有这些的话
给他们提供或者是
给他们进行一个
营销的指导
还有就是
线上销售的指导
对他来说都是比较有吸引力的
所以我们要重点突出卖点跟服务跟方案
大家一定要理解
这三个维度
而不是
单单从产品去展示
你产品上面去展示的时候一定是
呈现出客户的一个痛点
或者是说客户他想要解决的一个问题
通过产品的
卖点来呈现
来帮他解决问题
那么这样的产品的详情业
才更具有吸引力
才能够
让客户能够主动的给你发询盘或者是发TM咨询你
另外一个就是我们公司的优势提炼
我们就要去讲一下
我们这个行业买家
他看中的是什么
看中你这个企业的哪些维度
你把它列出来
123列出来
如果有很多条
那么你最终就把你觉得重要
业务调查买家之后发现
买家偏到哪些企业的优势
那么你就把这些优势
总结出来然后再去呈现给买家就可以了
你可以在海报
在首页
在详评页
多维度去呈现
第2个维度就是同行报款产品
他有什么样的特色内容可以提炼
我们把它的内容提炼出来
进行重新的
打造排版
比如说他的内容
按照什么顺序往下排的
比如说这个就是想要按照什么内容往下排的
那么我们
是不是可以参考他的内容的结构
排序的顺序
这样他的顺序按照这样排说明如果他转化很好说明他有一定的规律
或者是说更加符合买家的一个需求
所以我们要参考他的一个顺序
加内容的结构
加部分的经典内容的文案
这样就可以去做我们的爆款项景业了
第三个就是我们
自己产品的卖点提点
一定是要基于解决买家的需求
或者是说
解决买家的某一个难题的
去呈现了这样的产品才能够更加吸引买家
综合以上就是关于我们如何去突出公司优势
让客户信任你快速的成交
这些
只是其中的部分维度
当然你可以通过自己在实践的过程中
获得的启发或者是新的方法
不断的融合在你们的店铺里面去呈现
我相信这样的
店铺的转化率一定会更加好
好了
这节课我们就先讲到这里
下节课我们再见